he once starred on empire and turned out
to be a big old liar
disgraced actor is there any other kind
justice malette was found guilty of five
counts of disorderly conduct earlier
this evening in his hate crime hoax he
was on trial in chicago for faking an
attack on himself in 2019 creating a
phony story claiming that maga hat
wearing assailants beat him up tied a
noose around his neck because he was
black and gay it sounded so outlandish
it had to be fake and very much like
cat's hair
it was
the jury finding him
guilty he found him guilty today after
eight hours of deliberations earlier
smilet even took the stand in his own
defense saying quote there was no hoax
that's a strong defense but he couldn't
act his way out of this one
he now faces up to three years in prison
but most experts say he'll probably just
get probation and community service all
right uh i'll go to you joe first what
do you think of the verdict i i don't
think it could have gone any other way
yeah i want to know what that sixth
charge was that he seems to have not
been found guilty of because you know
that i don't know yeah because he
certainly he's not a good actor and we
found out he's not a very good director
yeah
and he certainly
he's not a good casting agent right
because for his white supremacists could
he have gotten two bigger blacker guys
to play the role i mean
but yes were shaquille o'neal and and
carl malone not available
and his special effects his noose looked
like a piece of linguine around his neck
i know come on and the best thing about
the news is that he had it under the
caller
yes put the news under the like the guy
i'm gonna put a news oh let's get it
under the caller
we're going to church later that's nice
but yeah it's funny the nigerians could
be accused of cultural appropriation
those roles were meant for white racists
exactly exactly and even even when they
challenged him on that and he said um he
said look i had a scratch under my eye
and you see these two gigantic guys that
the two of them against one it could
have been thirty jesse small against one
of those guys and they still would have
kicked his ass so
i'm so glad that we're not having a
discussion now of how he got away with
this and the impact of that he's a
terrible person he created a lot of very
bad energy and he could be looking at
his seriously uh a couple days of
probation committees yes
and then a reality show called i'm back
with jesse smilets
i never lied uh um this is a vindication
other joe
uh for nigerians
yeah getting a bad rap with the the
emails
uh you know we can only hope that
canceled culture doesn't doesn't ruin
their acting career
but to yes and joe's point uh
i relate to jesse smellette because i've
faked that i've won a number of fights
in fact
in fact all the fights i've ever won are
fake uh but
they never happen but if i cast those
two guys as my adversaries i'd like they
got a few shots in
[Laughter]
but but man that really gives actors a
bad a bad name just like just like
actors give their kids bad names
nicely done this guy's good yeah
cat
i think that smilet has kind of an
interesting insight into how the world
works that he doesn't i don't think he's
that worried that almost every calamity
can be turned into some kind of
opportunity that's why i think i do
think he's going to have his own show or
he's going to he probably won't sir
he'll probably go on probation and we'll
see him again i guess but he has to say
i did it
because i mean there's a video of the
rehearsal
there also there were rehearsals he put
so much time
into this
and spent no time thinking about it
which is remarkable to me because all
the steps finding these people
rehearsing it you know he's like yeah
i'll write him a personal check he'll be
fine yeah you know i don't but he didn't
think about it all but again how does he
even have a friend right now do they
have to be like yeah this is completely
unfair i can't believe i you were not
this was not a hoax you were hate crimed
you know i just
he has to say i did it no but you know
what i i it's a couple of things harold
and then i'll let you uh uh a his family
is believing him and i think i don't
know if that's for real but the other
thing too is he didn't really try to
prove his innocence he was hoping that
don't even you shouldn't care whether
i'm guilty or not you should just equip
me based on systemic racism and that
maybe that's why like maybe he's hoping
that the fact that he hoaxed people
won't matter i don't know that's the sad
and tragic part for me in addition to
everything that's been said and jury
seemed like i mean the justice seemed
like it was it was done this evening
there are people who are beating up on
the streets because they're gay yeah
there are people who are abused
because they're black or because they
are they're different than someone else
and for this guy
to do this i don't know this guy that
his family i would assume would be
supportive of him as any family would
um but this misappropriation of of of of
this labels and these accusations it
does nothing to advance the cause that i
think he at some level some part of him
genuinely wants to see supported which
is equality in society and better
treatment for people and how he did and
what he did he got what he deserved from
this jury this evening yeah i think that
but i think it always his ego came
before
a crusade or a desire for the betterment
of things what if by chance he becomes a
victim
of a real hate crime
you know there should be
we call it the boy who cried wolf what
do you think of that there's a scenario
right have you ever heard that before
yeah i always felt it was weird that
they let the boy
guard against the wolves to begin with
yeah that was true it was just a bit
yeah talking about bad casting that was
really bad casting very bad casting yes
no wonder he's a little weird yeah
what happens if a wolf comes and he's a
boy
all right before we go a really quick
reminder come see me i'll be in newark
new jersey
this sunday
g gut belt.com ticket information you'll
find it hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else